that right like can you give some
stereotypical like gender skills
gendered skills men are better with
things women are better with people
okay so like with that logic it would
make a lot of sense for men to be sent
to war because they're better at those
kind of things and then we make a lot
more sense for women to be leaders but
we're just not
women would be the Medics like like
women to be commanding and ruling and
like delegating tasks are meant to be
doing those tasks no but that's a
cognitive this is dissonance then
because you're saying that women are
better with working with people so like
directing people telling people to do
things are better are doing okay I
should say women are more interested in
doing jobs that have to deal with people
but when it comes to leadership women
don't excel in leadership like men do oh
so okay sorry can you just sorry because
because you can work you can work in
people with people as the checkout
person at a grocery store
like like leadership leadership no but
I'm saying like leadership and working
with people are two different sectors
but like you said like you said men are
good they wipe the hottest jobs
Plumbing electricity like everything
yeah if we look at men in that way that
that's their skill set
um in places like War it would make
sense that the women would be
controlling controlling and organizing
the war and that the men would actually
go out and fight but they wouldn't know
the all the logistics they have to be a
soldier themselves no no no no like when
people go to war the soldier doesn't
know everything they get given commands
there's someone from a general human
from somebody who's got experience and
actually yeah yeah the battlefield no no
most generals have never been on the
battlefield so how do they get what they
get the normal they normally go to
university they get degrees in like math
that's different there's different sort
of ranks so there's like if you're
talking about SAS then everyone's going
to be out in combat but if you're
talking about things like large Wars and
large things are organized by large
organizations like um like I'm let's say
like
you said the American Army it's not
going to be just organized by just
soldiers not everyone in that Army will
go and fight there'll be people that
will organize things they'll be
um intelligence surveillance things like
that people that collect information and
use it people that have like master's
degrees phds like maths right and
understands that I see I see your logic
I see a logic but where it's flawed is
that and this is from you can read you
know what have you heard the book
sapiens by Yovan
so in that book he talks about
um why female lit societies didn't do as
well as they should have done if your
examples were correct and they said that
when it comes to
um organizing groups men are better when
it comes to large scale whilst women are
better when it comes to small so small
social factions where it's like mothers
and the children when it when it large
scale you need to be able to yeah yeah
to unite people but and men are much
better providing that myth than women
are so by that same logic men are still
better at leadership than women will
because women are better and small
scales not large girls I understand what
you're saying one second we move this
down
um but I feel like what you're saying
applies
um to all genders so
um when you're with a large group of
people you need a common myth and I
don't think that's like
I don't think that's dependent on gender
and like Paul said before history tells
us it is though because again that book
depicts is that what the best the most
optimal function in society is what
lives the toe to tell so if women were
just as good at providing myth then it
would be massive female lead societies
that had their own let's just say like
they had their own continent that would
be doing their thing but they don't and
they had the opportunity to do so I'm
quoting the same book as you I'm quoting
the same example and a similar example
from this book and it says there's a
cognitive dissonance where
women have the skills to lead but
they're just not put in that leadership
role and then I have the typical but
then why don't you say they're not good
at it like I didn't say that one good at
it I'm just saying that women also have
the quality I'm saying like like okay
I could say oh I'm really good at
volleyball but if I never played and
never did it well then like like okay I
could say redheads are better at
volleyball
but then if redheads never play
volleyball and never do it well you
can't say redheads are better at
volleyball so saying like women are
better leaders but if they don't oh if
you use the example okay I'm good at
volley
um I'm gonna be good at volleyball but
you've never played and I say but
Pearl's a good athlete she'd probably be
good at volleyball that's probably
probably what I'm trying to say is that
women have the capacity to do these
things because they have these skills
from other places so they have people
skills they have listening skills they
can be quite organized they have a lot
of stamina for certainly I don't know
because I think the best leaders are
better they're not really the best
listeners they tell you what to do
I think the best leader is someone that
can is that was respected by other
people but can also understand what this
needs to be done now they can prioritize
this is a super chat it says the best
leaders are those who are not not only
good with people but they but they must
be able to have an
arbitrary or an impartial view on any
given Topic in Conflict which best
facilitates the larger good men are more
logical and empirical versus women
so it's just like yeah I feel like women
can prioritize
as well and if like that's a key
feeling it I feel like I feel like I
feel like it's all for you guys it's a
subjective opinion I know but I just
think like every I've always preferred
like male bosses because we get
emotional we get in our feelings with
stuff you know yeah women women and
women women okay that's true that is
true I don't really get on with the
women bosses but you know what
yeah at least you're honest about it
yeah when things are hard you you want a
man beside you that can make all the
hard decisions obviously a woman can as
well both both can do whatever it just
depends on you but large scale yeah like
I feel like what you're saying is like
really correlational like
but there's been studies to prove
because they didn't did the Scandinavian
study on on what women do when given
more opportunity to pick what they want
and it turns out that when women are
given opportunity they don't really pick
stuff I've seen those studies I'm just
saying that women have the capacity yeah
but they also did um a TV show where
they put like 15 men and 15 women on
like two islands and they had to like
figure out how to survive and like by
the first day like the men had figured
out how to get water how to hunt for
food they'd given everybody rolls and
like the women almost died three times
and the producers had to come in and
help them
the women are probably just talking
about what they're going to do yeah the
men are probably just like right Stacy
keeps telling me what to do that [ __ ]
no but it shows that the more the more
primitive the society the more gender
roles that they are it's easily assigned
so the more primitive to society is men
do this for women do that like we're
talking about Society like you've read
the book sapiens like after the
agriculture Revolution so let's talk
like if all if people hunter-gatherers
right now do you really think we'd be so
gender like everything we'll go back to
that because we'd go for what's most
optimal for survival because it's not
for you to go out and Hunt it's me no
but like wouldn't it be optimal that
we're both huntering and Gathering it's
most optimal that you're at home
pregnant with the babies preparing the
new generation whilst I'm out there
being Expendable bringing home the bacon
yeah like listen I want when I'm in when
I'm going bed I want my man has to go on
I would naturally expect him to sleep on
the side of the door at me closest to
the room that that doesn't mean
someone's got something's gonna happen
or even just things like uh you know
putting me to the side of the payment
and him walking on the side of the road
it's not like oh like men are
not important but I don't know I was
like a gentleman that's a lot of things
the first line of protection yeah like I
would just expect that anyway naturally
things like that just seem appealing to
me because just like oh like if
somebody's biological if somebody breaks
in at 3am you would naturally go and who
would naturally Tower away not that it's
a bad thing I'm gonna have him the bed
and expect a woman like to come and I
said babes go get that my point is
usually in a time of Crisis that's when
our natural selves come out because when
it's everything stable and calm or
whatever we can take have the privilege
of saying hypothetically I I could take
on a man's sure and when it actually
happens a perfect example Ukraine is we
live in a modern age people saw Ukraine
if you saw a tick tock when that was
going off every single feminist was like
listen I'm in the kitchen I didn't want
to go to war yeah literally no I I agree
with you I would never want to actually
engage in a fight on purpose like even
if I was like trained like to the top
level like all martial arts because I do
train martial arts I still wouldn't want
to pick a fight I would still always go
because why would I choose to put myself
in danger well that's like a martial art
like principle wouldn't it like to to
not deliberately go out exactly
I wish I could find this video but it
was a video that they showed um they
just went around recording random people
and they asked the men
um do I ask the women first if you had
to pick between you or your husband to
die who would you pick
and older women said him and then they
asked older men and all the men said me
and is this husband and wife the husband
and wife yeah
ouch
that is the perfect example of society
in like how women think because it was
there random selection
not everyone no I mean I don't think
everyone there's some women that would
be like no like take me not not you my
mom would say that my mom would say
rather her than me yeah but you're her
child of course any mother most women
are saying take the guy I mean it's the
same thing in the Titanic it was women
and children but I think that's like a
premise that they used to have in the
past that they wanted I think I think
that's natural like I think I think men
feel the innate instinct to protect
women the same way women have the innate
instinct to protect children when when
why is their violence towards women what
if they have an innate Instinct well
it's actually
um one-sided domestic abuse is more
common for the woman to be hitting the
man than the man to be hitting the woman
most domestic abuse situations they're
hitting each other so you can't yeah
like because a lot of girls do that
they'll say I was abused I was hit I was
whatever but but
they'll forget about the part where
they're like they're heading back and so
like like there is violence against
women but it's not it's not the norm but
doesn't that go against like the
intrinsic world to protect women yeah
when that I don't know go against the
laws of evolution for them to want to do
that I would say yeah it probably does
yeah but but that's why it's not normal
even when um even when you know uh from
uh holy books they say you know a woman
was made from Adam's Eve was made from
what Adam's Rib that's literally uh it's
not literal it literally means uh a man
needs to keep a woman under his arm for
protection and close to his heart like
it's not literal
so this is from way back as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick-Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible